[Musica]
spengono le luci sopra un mondo di garda
così
la città vecchia che risuona insomma
di giorno gli effetti di un sogno
pardi al vento resta un figlio cambiato
treno ha fischiato
non solo sta giocando poi versi c'è
qualcuno che ride e grida sa ci pare
la città mi adatto a fare
i nostri porti pensa
adesso che fuori non piove
dal sole
3 liquore
l'artista piaceva con cipressi
c'è chi doppia sempre senza soccorso
geranio sarà pato
infatti
la giornata sfuggente
la guarda
prende
agnelli
ho tante cose da dire
sti portare non reggano pensarci bene
sta bene
di pensarci bene
torino
pensaci bene
non fare i nostri morti
che se a volte fa male
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie pensaci bene a raccontare i
nostri ricordi
considero valore l'esercizio della
memoria e considero prezioso
forse il più prezioso che abbiamo l'atto
del ricordare i romani credevano che
ricordare volesse dire rimettere nel
cuore per loro la memoria infatti non
aveva niente a che fare con la ragione
con la mente per loro il ricordare un
affare di cuore in qualche modo credo
per questo che l'atto del ricordare
coincida molto più semplicemente con un
atto d'amore
la prossima canzone una canzone che ho
scritto ormai dieci anni fa era il 26
maggio del 2009 quando a montesanto
qualche isolato da qui fuori la cumana
venivano sparati dei proiettili
nell'aria i proiettili uscivano da
caricatori del club ricci il clan che
controlla la zona
il clan che in quei tempi era in faida
con il clan mariano che in questi giorni
è tornato dal collare le pagine dei
quotidiani perché il boss e stato
scarcerato i caricatori che sparavano
colpirono petru birlandeanu musicista di
strada
era arrivato in italia dalla romania
insieme alla moglie mirella ei suoi due
figli
quei progetti non cercavano per 3 0
tra i due una di quelle vittime
innocenti di criminalità 1 dopo esami
che affolla il registro di assenti
ingiustificati perché senza giustifica e
la loro morte
i proiettili fatto segnavano il
territorio i cani lo fanno con il piccio
loro invece la fanno con i proiettili
ai puri masi
per 30 minuti a terra davanti ai
tornelli della cumana
con accanto soltanto la monica
gela
i passanti che si guardava
semplicemente portavano la testa e sanda
e qui
torno in quei giorni che scrissi che
stavano solo
maledetta quei giorni
nessuno
parla
sempre al posto di libera popolare nella
nel 2016 siamo riusciti a far intitolare
la stazione di montesanto aperto la
riprova per me in qualche modo dal fatto
che un atto anche se musicale alle volte
può avere un impatto nella realtà viva
la lezione è per prima la considero un
atto d'amore
forse anche un atto di scusa
eto'o lascia il suo paese in un giorno
come tanti
in italia
era il suo re
supplenti
guarda
una scuola
non porta
alla fama
cerca
e un sogno
quello
non tanto sogno umano è davvero
non penso piacere quanto
canzoni sono come tu e respiri
un sorriso
uno sguardo alla gente che è seduta
qualche spesso gli basta per dirla vita
l'ho vissuta
mi scuso
segue
io
adesso cometa
sono proprio
troppo caldo
linee
pesante
provincia sono state sulla strada
il signore
vanno
mazzata
peggio berna
sofia
e sono otto
ma nessuno gli sta accanto
tutti
altra parte
punizione
lasciar respirare
scolpito
la morte
voglia di cambiare
a mio agio
le creature
ciò
con i suoi
è alta
le canzoni certe volte sono state
iscritte note ma le storie certe volte
come vedi per le strade
ricordi ancora patrucco e poi sognava
la generosa con la voglia e la speranza
i ricordi ancora pietro e moriva
abbandonato
se non c'eri non ricordi ora sai che
cosa è stato se non c'eri non ricordo ma
ora sai che cosa è stato e non ricordi
ma la sai cos'è
[Musica]
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]
la prossima canzone è quella che dà il
titolo all'album veniva citato poc'anzi
ed è quello che non siamo è una canzone
dedicata a chi parte da itaca e fa nel
viaggio in qualche modo una canzone che
dedico a chi parte chi parte è stata che
cosa fu già ma non sa che cosa cerca
continua qualcosa al etico in qualche
modo
agli amici partiti
[Musica]
cerca di una vita migliore all'altro
capo del mondo e la dedico a uomini e
donne e bambini
e di questi tempi navigano sul mar
mediterraneo in circa anche loro di una
vita migliore
sono loro per me gli invincibili
signor pedone sede a questa storia i
tuoi servi sono già partiti
la tua guerra
adesso non sto qua
sulla frontiera c'è una nuova vita la
sua voce chiama i sogni infranti milione
di uomini cominciano a sperare
primavera pulsa silenzio
cosa vista pensato che non
cosa
nessuna fuga nessuno
c'è una stazione per ogni attesa e
troveremo giorni il nostro posto del
c'era una volta una terra promessa
adesso siamo 6 ago
massimo oggi tra la parte o infondati
accesa lite
ancora tante vite a pezzi
per veti dentro questo inferno
nessuna memoria
si vendicherà
chi chiusi in regata scura
la nostra di una droga
se aspettiamo anche adesso
solo in questo libro
vero
senza nulla
c'è più volte ho sempre crede
noto per perder
la tiber
ancora provi a resistere a prendere
parte c'è quello che resta da mare
dove dorme per sempre il nostro destino
quando la rete stringe il cielo il mare
sono un fantasma può salvare il vuoto
fuori tempo l'ha sempre corriamo tutti
per niente ma donati dentro un brutto
sogno cerchiamo bene il filo che è
nascosto dritti fino al mattino
riprenderemo il cammino esisteremo anche
al peggiore male
oggi sappiamo solo l'essenziale quello
che non siamo quello che non vogliamo
[Musica]